我們可以先看一下上一個星期就是截止上週
上週的話我們看得到其實Hatchfong相對來說
Hatchfong投村相對來說比較謹慎吧
就是我們看到近幾個星期來有一次比較明顯的出貨
就從Hatchfong角度來說
Prime broker角度來說
其實這為什麼呢
就是這週的話市場有很多的incertity
那這中間最大的就是明天可能政府shed down
那這個事情我本身沒有覺得
我大會說一下歷來一來
就政府shed down對市場影響
但是這次可能不會那麼大吧就是
我又覺得政府shed down本身
然後呢那個第二就是在聯儲決議之後
有很多的美聯儲的委員就出來講話
包括昨天那個Hammock就是那個
Hammock相對來說比較硬派吧
就是包括J-PAL在上週講話相對來說也比市場認為
就是比市場預期的稍微強硬一點
那先說一下J-PAL因為這個J-PAL和Trump發生了一些
就是這個是Trump自己發的就是
他非常希望J-PAL降息講很快吧
至少在民意上他也希望J-PAL降息講很快
但是我之前講過就是上週我們就講到聯儲的一種
一種猶豫吧
因為聯儲本身他要對於inflation
然後對於增長這兩個東西要同時負責
那在那個政府政策沒有非常明確的時候
或者說政府政策造成的影響也沒有非常明確的時候
其實聯儲是很難去抉擇的
因為我們現在走的是一個貨幣的大周期
我們現在走的是財政的周期
財政的周期最後對於通脹式的沒影響的
然後會把經濟帶到比方說怎麼樣跟高的位置
包括我們上週的一些經濟數據都是側面表明了這些問題
就是我覺得聯儲相對來說會一直比較謹慎
那麼Trump非常對J-PAL一直在施壓
就說到希望美聯儲快速降息
美聯儲主席J-PAL也在有一次訪問中間說到了這個問題
他說到他這次pacautious
就是有一點魅雨出膜的成分在裡面
然後做了降息
同時的話這一次降息對於股票的影響
他提到了股票當中存在泡沫
但是如果你聽那個全文的話
其實J-PAL就講到了他對於通脹和對於增長兩個影響
就反覆重複這個事情
我們是dugo
然後我們要同時兼顧通脹要同時兼顧增長
但是人家問到股市的估值是不是過高
這個事情他並不是主動去講的
就是他是連帶帶到一局
因為那個主持人一直在問
所以就帶到了一局
那個確實股市中間存在估值過高的問題
blahblah講了一些
那麼這些都被市場認為就是在聯儲層面
就是市場就是聯儲層面
貨幣供應房民
那麼相對來說還比較 cautious
比較謹慎一點
那麼這件事情跟我們之前的判斷其實並沒有區表
就是我一直沒有覺得是一個放水大周期
就是即使現在你把它類比成中國2008年那樣
那麼它可能是個財政相對來說更大的周期
但是它並不是一個放水的大周期
就是貨幣政策的大周期
如果說要等到聯那個美國國家負債過高
然後要進入放水的周期
那其實這個周期滿長的
就是中國走完這個周期
中國是從那個2008年開始走
那個貨幣周期
貨幣周期走完那個現在資不理戰的那個負債過高
開始拼命的走財政貨幣雙周期那下稿
那這個我覺得美國遠遠沒到這個需要去下稿的這個境界
那麼當話我會說一下
我包括我前兩天聽摩根斯丹利的那個摩根斯丹利的
SIM Manager們的CIO講到我們現在在一個美國CAPEX周期
那我覺得這個我挺認同的
就是美國現在在一個CAPEX的周期裡面
跟中國的區別是中國2008年開始走CAPEX的周期
然後CAPEX周期的過程中間
它的那個邊際效率在下降
就是我頭鐵路頭工廠那個邊際效率在下降
但是美國現在邊際效率還沒有下降
就是它的CAPEX的收益率還是非常好的
所以這個CAPEX周期還是可以走
就是效率提升效率提升這過程還是可以走一段時間
所以你說到白宮和聯儲的本質的區別是什麼
白宮更關心的是我能不能在這個AI的周期裡面
大規模的走CAPEX
然後通過CAPEX提高效率
提高效率的那個通脹自然就過下來
然後我需要去監管
就包括明年對於金融公司的去監管
然後我需要更多的花錢
那BBB法案就是更多花錢減稅
然後希望在這過程中同時把效率提升起來
那這個可能是我們一想情願的覺得MACA
就是覺得穿過他們的想法
那麼聯儲的這個想法就是你做減稅
你做這個政府的這個CAPEX
那結果就有可能會導致通脹
包括你的tariff關稅
那這些都會導致通脹
所以我在財政政策 貨幣政策上面
我要相對來說謹慎
那我等你那個政策出來
然後我在評估它影響
然後我再做決定
那麼做了這麼多
上週的話更加重要的就是短期來說
市場就在關炸兩個
一個是聯儲FOMC冷了以後
聯儲的幾個委員都要表態
就是看一下他們未來對於利率市場的政策
現在市場就是經過這一些東西之後
覺得不是很確定
那麼可能回到我們之前的預期
就是不太會大規模降息
Terminal Rate在3%左右
那麼我還是覺得今年還是會降兩次
因為聯儲一般來說
他比較喜歡保持自己的貨幣的一致性
倒不是因為創不要說什麼
他的這個一致性的保持
還是相對來說做的比較好的
所以他如果做覺得
Pacosius的9月份要
就是根據前一段的數據
在9月份要降一次息
那麼根據後面的數據的話
雖然我們到外面會講到這個數據的問題
數據的話Q2的GDP是不錯的
Q2GDP是比預期要高308
所以這個也帶動了
很多人就覺得今年下半年
會不會不降息了
我覺得不太會
Q2本身這個GDP
我們就沒有覺得它會很差
其實我一直覺得GDP會比較差的是
四季度和明年的一季度
就是你的政策是需要一個時間
然後來體現的
它並不是我關稅出來之後
關稅出來之後
很多公司把中間的關稅先給吃掉了
其實Pasco rate
就Pasco過去的Pasco投資人
那裡大概就消費者
那裡大概只有50%
但是這個比率會變得更大
所以對於不管是通脹的影響也好
對於經濟增長的影響也好
這個影響都是需要時間來體現
那麼這個時間最少是6月
那你4月份最少是10月份
那一樣你減稅的政策
我們說明年的整個CAPEX的impose是正面的
就整個明年的CAPEX的impose可能會
對GDP的影響可能會在50個basis point左右
所以從Q1
就是從不是Q1
從first half來說
前半年就Q1加Q2來說
那個physical policy
它的財政政策的總體影響
就是開始變得正面了
那主要是第二季度
明年第二季度
所以這個影響也是從GDP來說
它的影響也是需要時間之後的
也得6個月的
所以你11月份
如果真的能夠把這個政策出來
我們待會講到它政府關門的事情了
那麼它的影響也要到明年1季度以後
所以經濟數據
你不要看2季度經濟數據3.8
看上去還不錯
但是那個3季度4季度的本身數據面
我都不會覺得很好
然後既然前幾次能方佩洛
導致了就是下條數據比較差
導致連儲的降息
加上它的3四季度4季度
我覺得數據不會太好了
然後四季度明年一季度數據都不會太好
然後它的政策又需要有一些延續性
所以我覺得今年還是會繼續降兩次
就至少要降一次
一次到兩次的洗
兩次概率挺大的
所以這個是我對短期的一個看法
那麼但是terminal rate
就是長期的利率
我就是覺得在3%
然後在這個過程中間
在重複
在這個過程中間
不是降息利率會下去的
降息的長短利率很難下的去的
長短利率跟國債的需求也有關係
就比方說明年的國債需求
又是可能是個大年
所以這些需求端的影響結合起來
長短利率不太會因為短期降期
會下特別多
所以在怎麼說呢
現在如果說政府官們這個事情
能夠對長短利率有一些往下的影響
因為你看過去幾次
對股票不一定有很大的影響
但是政府官們這個事情
對長短利率往往會有一些影響
就是如果能夠長短利率被打回4.05左右
再能夠跌回去的話
我覺得一個steeping trade
steeping就是利率變抖的交易
又會出現機會
但是不知道有沒有這個機會
我覺得利率在短期
被一些新聞打擊的可能蠻大的
但是年底的平衡的價位
大概就在4.2左右
4.1到4.25這樣的一個水平
這個觀點我倒是一直沒有改變過
對於利率的這個觀點
差不多我覺得就應該在這個水平裡面
所以你如果是做raids trading的話
我覺得看看市場給不給這樣的一個機會
因為我覺得後面的就是
payroll的水平大概在5萬左右
但是我不知道星期五還能不能報的出來
星期五有可能政府官們就不報了
然後implement接近4.3萬
這個我覺得影響還是比較大的
這可能還是比較大的
現在美國
tire of的影響基本上過去了
因為關稅的政策
除了一些細則上
比方說上週他要對於境外進口的芯片加稅
然後要對於那個藥廠不在美國生產加稅
這個都很不搞
因為藥本身就不是靠生產
藥這個東西靠看業界的
現在美國藥的最大的問題
我被中國取代的是
美國做一個案例的成本
可能是中國的100倍
就是招募患者做一個成本
是中國這個上百
100倍不到吧
10倍是絕對有幾十倍
那你問題是你做一個人都是一樣的
你在中國做一個招募患者
然後流程也更順暢
也沒有那麼多麻煩的事情
對吧
你在美國招募患者這麼貴
所以過三季臨床很累
你在中國做新藥的成本低很多
然後藥的研發這個才是問題
所以你
而且你把這麼多基礎的醫療上面的撥款
包括現在聽說
哈佛的醫學學院都已經不招人了
都已經教授工資都快發不出來
然後那個
姜浩克斯已經經驗已經博士生全部不招
所以你說從醫療行業往中國轉
是不是靠醫療生產的完全不是
所以他的很多關稅都是完全無理團
就是特朗普這政策是完全是無理團
但是普拉賽這個就是關稅影響
大頭我覺得可能過去
我們沒有Pricing的影響
是Labor Market的影響
是勞力成本的影響
也就是說移民對這個市場影響有多大
為什麼移民今年我們之前覺得
移民也是一個比較大的風險因素
為什麼移民
我覺得還沒有對包括GDP
包括Inflation的影響
沒有這麼大的體現出來
其實你要看
我這邊沒有把這個數據列上去
你覺得你中間要看一個數據
就是Labor Force Participation
Labor就是勞工的參與度
勞工的參與度其實一直在提高在美國
也就是說本身不工作的人
在填補這個勞動力的缺口
使得勞動力沒有那麼貴
使得勞動力的價格維持在現代水平
通常不上升
Service價錢沒上去
外部的移民雖然沒有進來
它內部的動員力在上升
但是Participation Rate這個東西是有上限的
就是它並不是能夠一直提升
就是你把美國不工作人都變工作
它裡面有40%是OBIS的人
那些人怎麼工作
那麼這個有上限
所以包括在今年晚一點的時候
我覺得這方面在移民政策上影響也會出來
因為現在有更嚴格的移民政策
包括對H1
我們上星期講到對H1B的影響
包括我們講到後面可能會去
對於那個原來的那個有一些移民經濟驅逐
有11個冥領
就是1100萬那個各類的這種移民在美國
所以他們都有可能有一部分人擔心不出來工作
所以這個存量的影響是對於
存量影響是相比於
就是說增量更加重要的一個因素
那麼當然這幾個因素
可以在短期裡面被你的參與度提高影響
但是最終會體現在你的通脹上面
也會體現在你的這個增長上面
所以政策層面的不確定性還是
怎麼說呢還是存在
就是這幾個
但是整體來說美國現在是一個CAPEX週期
這個比較讓人樂觀的是
在這個CAPEX週期開始的時候
美國的Household Balance是非常健康
就是老百姓的資產負債表比較健康
因為中國的總負債總存款
基本上總負債已經是高於總存款百分之二十幾萬
二十三十萬現在
所以中國的資產負債表也就是說
居民資產負債表非常差
居民的收入也很差
就中國的居民收入可能是在
Dispensable income
就是在百分之四十左右
在全國百分之四十左右
就全國GDP百分之四十
美國在百分之八十
然後Household Networks還在提高
這個過程可能中間跟股票是比較相關的
中國如果希望通過股市的上漲
提高Household Balance
這件事情是不可能完成的
中國的股市或者說是資本市場的
整體的我們叫做尾部非常非常大
就是貧富分部非常非常不平均
並不是401K代表養老金全部投在裡面
它跟美國狀態不太一樣
然後所以就是說
這個反而在中國不太能形成
但是在美國確實人家現在的居民的
資產負債表相對比較好
再加上你在AI投入
現在大量的做CAPEX
AI投入上
它的我剛剛講到它Majin非常好
Majin很高
所以這個大的週期裡面
確實它另外一方面
就是你會看勞工成本
同時的話
可能會導致它Projectivity growth
這個是歸股和很多在歸股
壓住的一個最重要的東西
就是這一次革命能不能代表
這就是我們的效率的提升
效率提升一切都可能就有
所以這也是個很大的壓住
那麼在短期裡面的那個
我是覺得因為昨天晚上的那個3點鐘
那個參議院那個少數派領袖
和那個多數派領袖
加上Trump其實是有一個catch up
大家有開會了
那麼我是這個已經沒有更新了
這個現在Polymarket上
可能在70以上了吧
那個就是美國明天
政府官們的概率還是非常大
那麼這也是對中進行上週
有很多出貨的一個原因吧
就是政府可能會官吻
然後對資本市場可能會有影響
首先我們看一下過去幾次
對資本市場影響
影響比較嚴重的
可能是在2018年那一次
就是那一次
包括2013年那一次也有比較大影響
但是這些影響更多的是
在政府官門之前
就是大家覺得這個東西要來了
然後就影響就會體現出來
那這次不同的是
大家覺得它來了
能市場沒有底了
市場反而漲了 對吧
那麼一般政府真的官門
會對經濟造成影響嗎
我覺得這次官門
如果真的是關一個多星期
大家會對就業有個
對GDP有個大概10%的
20個BaseSpoint
在Q3也大概有這樣的影響
並不是那麼嚴重
那麼第二就是以前
就過往來年來看的話
就是股票市場
那麼一般來說
官門時間都不會特別長
就是官門之後
哪怕像2018年
官門這麼長時間
最後對於市場net的影響
其實不一定是負面
因為有幾個方面考慮
第一個就是市場
是pricing和不pricing的影響
雖然就業數據會變差
但是大家都知道它是WWE
你們知道這什麼意思
就是打了完的
最終這個問題總能解決
並不說政府官門了
美國委員
這個是沒有可能性的
第二就是一般來說
政府官門導致經濟
會變差那麼一點的
同時聯儲政策會變得更鬆
因為聯儲本身就是在不確定上
它就不敢動
但是如果有一個方向
變化的話它就會動了
所以聯儲政策往往會變得
更加鬆一點
所以不太會導致
因為政府官門
有人說美國政府加權違約
或者是對於市場造成很davis-dealing
就是非常惡性的影響
現在看來不太會
就是過去幾次都不太會
但是畢竟是一個很負面的事情
一般來說在這個事情發生之前
市場就一般就下跌過了
但是這次是沒有
那麼說一下
就是我覺得這次為什麼
肯定會關門
其實我之前就一直覺得它會關門
就是包括在推特上
都說它會關門
它關門的主要原因是
本身眾議院已經出了一個法案
就是讓這個7個星期的延後
把這個延後到7個星期
11月份才做決定
但是在參議院裡面的那個
民主黨不同意
然後民主黨要達到表決
雖然民主黨是少出派
但是民主黨要直接投票
結束變成投票表決
其實是需要60票
現在民主黨沒有到60票
51票53票
然後民主黨是沒有到絕對多數票
所以沒有辦法馬上進行表決
那麼民主黨就可以拖著這個事情
不讓它通過
不讓它通過政府的方令
在明天要用完了
所以沒辦法的情況下
它就有可能要關門
就是政府可能面臨 shut down
因為方令用完了
然後中間辯論的一個最核心的點
是Acea
就是affordable care
是就叫做Acea
是奧巴馬的可忍受
什麼可承受醫療
affordable care
然後就相當於是民主黨這幾年指責
就是在至少在奧巴馬時代
指贈的一個認為是自己的一個成就
那麼也是共和黨認為
它一個大的失敗
所以在這個法案
其實它的一些補助會被延續
所以它其實是希望
川普先把Acea的這個補助
能夠延續下去
那麼對於特朗普來說
這是一個
它的政治上攻擊的一個焦點
而且是馬尬黨人
非常討厭的一個東西
所以它一定是要把這個東西
給否決掉
就是一個是我認為的是寶貝
一個是我認為的是垃圾
所以兩邊的辯論的焦點都很強
第二
霍普很希望
因為他其實除了
昨天以色列那邊說
可能會停火什麼的
那其實他在政治上
很多的事情都沒有見述
他非常想表現成一個政治強人
那麼在這件事情上
他就是之前先是表現政治強人
然後不跟人家談判
然後昨天談判之後又
其實昨天談判是一個形式的談判
就是他要表現政治強人
他就不能讓民主黨得逞
所以他又說
如果說你們把政府關門
我就把你們這幫左派
在政府裡的員工直接解僱掉
因為原來很多政府關門是
能pay leave
然後讓你們先回家買
然後回去
到時候再拿到經費再來工作
他把你永久解僱掉
那麼就是要搞
政府內大清洗
就是你不讓我通過
我就搞你的人
所以他要表現這種政治強人
跟民主黨那邊的態度一樣
民主黨要刷存在板
就是川普導致了美國大部分人很反對他
其實川普最大的問題是
他動搖了美國
agency independent
就是我們叫做機構的獨立性
和美國很多很多機構都是有獨立性
包括美聯儲
他機構獨立性
各自起旨
所以他的權力分散性
就不搞獨裁
人家不搞獨裁
所以非常像就是
2019年的時候
很多中國人的反抗
就是或者香港的反抗
這個是相似度比較高的一個東西
所以在2011
就是現在的話
就是美國的問題
就在於這個地方
大家反抗川普
那麼民主黨要刷存在板
他刷存在板的話
他的問題就來了
他必須這一次要跟川普就剛上了
所以政府官們的概率
在這個時點上是比較高的
我覺得
但是他會不會關很長時間
那有我才會
因為我看昨天的會議
主要是在一個什麼焦點
昨天的會議的焦點
就在於誰的過
就是民主黨和共和黨
都說你們不願意談
所以導致可能政府會關門
所以我談一下
到時候還是可以談一下
然後繼續把它打開
所以我覺得可能
並不會像2018年這麼長時間
大概率可能就是幾天
一個星期
這是我個人的感覺
就是大家都必須要刷一下存在板
畢竟現在讓政府關門時間太長
這個對於中期選舉的影響
還是蠻大的
就馬上明年中期選舉了
而且特別是維吉尼爾
就這個地方
也要改選參議院
所以川普要去掃掉維吉尼爾的
這些政府僱員
也是為了這個原因
就已經動搖你的選票
所以大家都不太敢賭的太大
但是都必須要刷一下存在桿
那麼政府官們
我覺得明天概率基本上是大概率
然後不會關於太長的時間
對於市場影響
我個人覺得不會特別大
會不會像18年這樣
對於美元利率有個
18年很大
那表示像
對於美元利率有個
是個basis point of impact
我覺得不太確定
如果有的話
那麼就是個機會
我一直不覺得
長達利率會因為降息
什麼東西
直接下去太多的
最後講一下美國independent
就是agency independent
就是這些他的機構的獨立性問題
其實中間有個很重要的案例
大家可以觀察一下
就是特朗普政府
在各個機構部門
都想獲得更大權力
這個是在美國
任何一個前任總統
都沒有幹過的事情
Nixon被水門事件彈劾
是因為他阻撓司法公正
他要求自己的司法部長
去解雇一個去調查
自己的總檢察官
是這個把他給拖下水
但是特朗普其實
對了COMEY
幹了類似的事情
因為COMEY原來
FBI的COMEY
他原來去調查
通俄門的事件的時候
他等於是幫了特朗普選上選
那個16年的時候
他和那個希拉里兩個人對選
然後希拉里其實
那個時候領先
他將近10個點
就是最後一個星期
那個COMEY說
他確實在調查希拉里
然後導致希拉里選崩了
但是後來他當然跟特朗普
分道揚鑣了
那個現在他退役之後
那個司法部長下面的檢察官
就不想對他提及訴訟
特朗普明確在搜尋上面說
為什麼不對他提及訴訟
然後要把原來的檢察官給換掉
換成自己的一個Personal Lawyer
然後讓他去提出那個訴訟
所以這個事情是一個非常明確的
那個阻礙司法公正
那麼這個就是大家反對特朗普
其實並不是反對很多他的政策
不是真的是左派
而是說他影響了美國的很多獨立性
那麼在經濟上面影響最大的獨立性
就是莉莎庫克的這個case
就是他能夠用他不是
就是莉莎不是在那個美聯儲的時候的
一個什麼事情
好像是Mogage什麼
這個申報Mogage什麼一個事情
很小的事情
然後拿這個作為一個
這個叫做正當性理由
去要去解雇莉莎
所以這個案子到了美國
等於是到了法院
下層法院都把他那個政府判輸了
所以這個case現在
他們緊急送到最高法院
要求最高法院判
那麼現在情況看來
就是這個也是我們今天掛在頭上的
這個事情
就是他要發言那個J票
他有沒有能力發言J票
那麼現在看來我覺得是沒有能力的
但是對那個莉莎他都發言不了
不要說發言J票
那莉莎的case現在到了最高法院
那麼在最高法院上現在看來的話
我覺得對於川普政府不是很有利
因為最高法院如果是傾向於希望
就是說傾向於川普的話
他可以先把這個下面巡迴法院的
那個判決先給停止掉
然後呢
我在審閱這個case
然後再看
現在最高法院還沒有給他respond
就是沒有把那個下面的給停掉
莉莎普還是繼續參加了
美聯儲會一樣
就是7號呢
我以為他還是參加了
然後這個意味著就有可能
這個判決就是會對莉莎有利
包括現在我們前任幾個美聯儲主席
他們都在那個最高法院
很明確的去說到提出的
就是美聯儲的奴隸性對於美國經濟運行
對於美元本身
美元的信用都是非常非常重要的
就是他不能像中國人民銀行一樣
驅從於財政部讓你印錢你就印
對吧
讓你印錢也就印
你的好處是國家可以無限的權力
他可以不停的印錢花錢像中國
然後但是壞處是
他會把居民可自費收入打得很低
變成一個國家主導的
對吧
就是那個權力集中的這麼一個政府
但是呢
在包括以後對於貨幣的信用都會有影響
那麼
那麼在美國的話呢
就是這個呢
我覺得這一次判決不太會成功
就是特朗普政府的判決不太會成功
今天聊了太多關於那個美國政治的事情
我們先說到這裡
然後看看有沒有Q&A把
看看大家有什麼問題